más
vamos en camino al departamento de arte
pero no podemos mostrarlo todo porque lo
que está ahí es ultra secreto en el
vídeo pasado vimos cómo se crearon
patrones para darle textura al
dinosaurio arlo en la película el viaje
de arlog en esta lección ahora tú vas a
crear una piel de dinosaurio convincente
usando patrones colores y dispersión te
presentaremos algunas técnicas usadas
aquí en pixar como los diagramas de
voronoi y cómo usamos la dispersión para
hacer que se vea más orgánico al final
de esta lección estarás listo para crear
tu propia piel de dinosaurio y no
importa lo que estemos construyendo todo
inicia con un paquete de acabados y los
paquetes de acabados los hacen artistas
del departamento de arte como tía
hola hola hola cómo están ustedes super
muy bien les tengo un regalo el paquete
de acabados para la pierna del
dinosaurio aquí tienen algunas piezas
algunas referencias algunas
especificaciones de colores y referencia
real esto es para las garras
no tengo todas las respuestas así que se
los encargo a ustedes tengo que ir a dar
una clase les puedo encargar esto pueden
usar mi oficina que se diviertan gracias
gracias genial gracias a dios
el paquete de acabados es una colección
de dibujos e imágenes que nos guiarán en
el proceso de crear nuestra piel de
dinosaurio todo inicia en papel porque
es más fácil hacer iteraciones ahí el
paquete de acabados también contiene
referencias como este cactus que es una
aproximación real de la vista y textura
que queremos es una maravillosa
inspiración para las escamas de nuestro
dinosaurio pero es solo un punto de
inicio examinemos estos dibujos con más
atención y veamos qué tipo de cosas ha
identificado tía observa que hay muchas
escamas de varios tamaños que sobresalen
de la piel necesitamos averiguar cómo
construirlas fíjate en que las escamas
varían en tamaño algunas son más
pequeñas otras más grandes las escamas
grandes corresponden a las áreas rígidas
como la parte media de la pierna las
escamas pequeñas se encuentran en el
área cercana a las garras que es un área
más flexible además del tamaño posición
y forma de las escamas también
necesitamos pensar en el color
observa que ella quiere variaciones de
color en las escamas y nos hace notar
que la piel va con las escamas debe
tener un color distinto el toque final
es poner atención a los distintos tipos
de las variaciones de dispersión que
necesitamos por ejemplo algunas escamas
sobresalen más que otras y además el
tamaño y la posición de las escamas
también debe de variar así es que hay un
montón de variación por aquí ahora te
toca examinar el paquete de acabados una
vez que te sientas cómodo examinando
paquetes de acabados trabajaremos
creando los patrones en la computadora